là
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous rendez vous
hebdomadaire pour débattre et discuter
réfléchir des sujets qui font
l'actualité
des sites inscrits au titre des
monuments nationaux d'autres reconnu
patrimoine d'intérêt régional des
édifices et des objets historiques les
yvelines regorge de lieux d'histoire qui
doivent être sauvegardées c'est l'une
des missions de nos trois invités
françoise lefèvre bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes documentaliste au simple
d'ingénierie agence départementale au
service de l'urbanisme et du patrimoine
yvelinois frédéric debussche bonsoir 7
conservateur du musée de la ville de
saint quentin en émule lessard a scellé
bonsoir ça et restauratrice
restauratrice de meubles anciens à
versailles alors on vient d'annoncer
qu'un sujet ce qu'il ya un chantier de
restauration qui se déplace au val
fourré c'est le château de versailles
qui délocalisent pour deux ans à
mantes-la-jolie quatre statues
colossales qui ont pris place dans
l'ancienne usine de matelas dunlopillo
regardez c'est acté convention signée
entre les départements des yvelines et
le château de versailles pour la mise en
place du chantier de restauration de
quatre groupes sculptés sur l'ancienne
friche du site industriel dunlopillo
situe à mantes la jolie pour l'instant
de son surplace découpé en 85 palette
elle trônait normalement sur les piliers
des grilles de l'orangerie du château de
versailles la restauration va durer
environ 18 mois en septembre prochain
cet espace sera ouvert aux visiteurs un
jour par semaine on va montrer ce
travail aux habitants de
de mantes-la-jolie aux jeunes qui
pourront venir à la fois voir ce que
sont ces métiers le voir en temps réel
pouvoir même s'exercer à ce travail et
puis comprendre l'importance que ak ce
patrimoine non pas par rapport au passé
mais par rapport à l'avenir avant
l'ouverture tout public une première
opération aura lieu cet été auprès des
jeunes issus des quartiers politique de
la ville et de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance dans le cadre de l'été royal
entre juillet et août ce seront trois
mille jeunes à peu près entre 6 ans et
18 ans donc avec des ateliers prévus
pour eux est adapté à ce qu'il à leur
âge notamment et bien qu'ils pourront
venir ici découvrir ses travaux autour
de la pierre et puis ensuite venir
découvrir le château de versailles lors
de la signature de la convention le
département des yvelines a officialisé
la création d'un tiers lieux culturels
sur le site de lusine dunlopillo fermé
depuis 2020 diverses associations
orienté cultures urbaines comme le graff
le breakdance ou encore la glisse
urbaine était présente pour donner un
avant goût de ce que va devenir cet
espace 2000 440 m² plutôt que d'avoir
une espèce de friches qu'on garde yens
ou alors aux comptes démolissent tous
les bâtiments et connaît un espace vide
absolument pas glamour et sans usage ça
serait vraiment dommage et ça va être le
premier tiers lieux
anne ile-de-france eux
en grande couronne un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt va donc être
lancée en attendant le bâtiment et ses
abords sont en cours de rénovation
coût total des travaux estimé à un peu
moins d'un million d'euros alors ce
chantier s'intègre dans une aide
exceptionnelle de 15 millions d'euros
sur trois ans voté par le département
pour soutenir le château de versailles
françoise lefèvre dans les yvelines il
existe un dispositif
restauration des patrimoines historiques
2020 2023 ils concernent exclusivement
la restauration du patrimoine historique
monumentale mobilier et documentaires
c'était bien fin
alors exclusivement c'est effectivement
déjà très vaste
c'est un dispositif qui permet aux
communes de demander des subventions
pour la restauration de leur patrimoine
parce que les communes sont
propriétaires de patrimoine d'un
patrimoine historique
qui est relativement cher à entretenir
en particulier pour des petites communes
rurales et c'est à cet effet que le
département a mis en place ces
dispositifs de subventions donc qui se
décline avec ce dispositif des dons à la
restauration du patrimoine historique il
ya un dispositif qui est tout nouveau
qui lui concernent des carnets
d'entretien parce qu'on a constaté qu'il
valait mieux prévenir que guérir et donc
pour pouvoir aider les communes à
prendre soin de leur patrimoine au
quotidien on a mis en place ce
dispositif d'entretien et il ya un
troisième dispositif qui lui et les
fonds d'urgence quand il ya vraiment une
catastrophe et c'est un dispositif qui
est apparue en 2016 après la grande
inondation
qui a révélé l'urgence dans ce cas
d'arrivée chez beaucoup de sites voilà
exactement
51 des mines regorge de lieux
patrimoniaux en 2014 trois sites de
l'agglomération sur la balise et
patrimoine d'intérêt rêve d'intégrer
pardon par la région ile de france
frédéric debussche ça apporte quelque
chose en particulier ce label
petite précision
2010neuf utilisation de trois oeuvres de
l'art public en fait 2014 est impossible
puisque c'est un label qui n'était pas
encore
17 par la région ile de france et c'est
un label de reconnaissance
du patrimoine francilien donc un
patrimoine d'intérêt régional et
effectivement la candidate est assez
rapidement pour présenter un dossier nar
public réunissant trois oeuvres trois
oeuvres majeures du territoire donc vous
les avez cités ils ingèrent monumental
voilà il ya la porte de paris avec large
de commerce qui
mercado
qui symbolisent les
sources de la bièvre et puis au débouché
du canal urbain à l'oeuvre de marta pan
la perspective qui effraie la fin de nos
studios ça à ses livres est la toute
nouvelle gérante de l'atelier des
sycomores aversa et votre spécialisation
les meubles anciens ça demande un savoir
très particulier imagine mal côté oui il
faut effectivement connaître les
méthodes utilisées à l'époque donc non
est spécialisé dans les siècles 17 18 et
19e
donc il faut connaître tout c'est les
méthodes de fabrication donc
d'ébénisterie d'époque pour restaurer de
la même manière utilise les méthodes
anciennes écoles l'ancien les
assemblages anciens le placage ciller
donc il faut compter sans dénaturer pour
ne pas dénaturer le taf est l'oeuvre si
je peux utiliser selon exactement le but
pour nous c'est de ne pas montrer qu'on
est con est intervenue voilà exactement
et quand quand c'est le cas on est mené
les plus plusieurs voilà par l'immeuble
souvent c'est lié à des déplacements
quand ça s'abîme à 50 ans nul les
oeuvres elles sont plutôt d'art urbain
elles sont au nombre de 40 soumises aux
intempéries c'est plus dur d'être aux
petits soins de ses ouvrages
c'est effectivement un patrimoine qu'il
faut entretenir lorsqu'il est déjà
important c'est de faire reconnaître ses
oeuvres en tant que quels éléments du
patrimoine les sas est en phase de
devenir il y à une fort attachement je
pense aussi bien là de la population
mais aussi la collectivité à 7 cette
collection est
et une volonté une vraie volonté pour
entretenir ce désordre qui ont pour
certaines déjà une quarantaine d'années
d'existence elles sont à l'air libre
elles sont donc soumises un temple à vie
mais aussi bien sûr au vandalisme et
puis à l'usure du temps
naturellement après il y en a certaines
qui sont réalisés dans des matériaux qui
sont un peu fragiles nous tout cela
demande une politique d'entretien et qui
est mise en oeuvre notamment par par le
musée de la ville à la fois une
politique d'entretien et de restauration
puisque l'idée c'est
comme le disait madame le fun ii d'avoir
une politique entretient c'est très
important pour éviter que les hommes
sont dans un état trop dégradée
d'arriver trop tard
des moments où il faut vraiment passer à
une phase de restauration et là c'est
une politique qui engage m écrans depuis
trois ans et on est à une douzaine de
chantiers engagés soit sur des
restauration proprement dit des deux
interventions d'entretien ou alors des
études préalables qui qui permettent de
dresser les pistes
sortie de vente est retenu pour la
restauration de la doller françoise
lefèvre ont parlé ça que j'ai dit 2014
que ces deux cadors céline générique est
lancé vous l'avez dit ça participe à la
conservation restauration c'est les
hince quand même 500 édifices protégés
au titre des monuments historiques mais
6000 qui ne le sont pas c'est ce qui
impacte les communes notamment j'imagine
les églises on avait fait un sujet qui
n'existent du dos sur une église du 12e
siècle qui devait être entretenu tout à
fait c'est vraiment un sujet très
important on voit même on l'a vu
récemment dans la presse quand une
église quand un village perd son église
parce qu'on ne peut plus le village n'a
plus les moyens de de la restaurer c'est
pour une pour le village pour les
habitants c'est en même temps la perte
de leur identité la perte de repères
c'est l'endroit où ils se sont mariés
d'endroits où leurs parents ont été
enterrés
c'est quelque chose de crucial donc pour
nous c'est très important d'entretenir
ce patrimoine au titre de cette mémoire
mais également parce que bien souvent le
l'église c'est le premier musée de du
village parce que c'est pas seulement un
édifice mais c'est aussi un endroit qui
accueille un certain nombre d'objets le
plus souvent des objets religieux
parfois des objets un peu plus un peu
moins traditionnel mais c'est la
première confrontation avec un objet
d'art que peut avoir que peuvent avoir
les citoyens c'est les communes qui
viennent vers vous c'est une générique
qui prospecte aussi un petit peu pour se
rendre compte de l'état des lieux ça se
passe dans les deux sens c'est à dire
qu'au début il ya eu un travail de avec
un bâton de pèlerin pour aller
convaincre les communes que ça pouvait
être intéressant pour eux de faire appel
à ce genre de dispositif et puis le
bouche à oreille à ces faits et les
maintenances et les communes qui nous
sollicitent donc ça se fait dans les
deux sens ça a saigné vous vous
travaillez pour les particuliers vous
êtes aussi amener sur des gros chantiers
quand je dis gros chantier qui savaient
le château de versailles qui est pas
loin ça vous arrive de travailler aussi
avec eux alors nous notre clientèle
enfin ma clientèle est plus et plus
comment dire particulièrement
ce sont des particuliers voilà les
privés après il nous arrive de
travailler pour le mobilier national
enfin à l'époque c'était le cas
maintenant ça va revenir un petit peu
mais effectivement on a deux ont peur de
beaux chantiers et le but c'est de ne
pas grandir ces deux pas de pas
justement rester sur une clientèle
privée mais s'ouvrir le plus possible de
grands chantiers nous ce que vous
récupérez un atelier celles de alain de
la valade il est expert auprès de la
cour d'appel de versailles a notamment
cédé expertise que vous allez garder bah
écoute et oui je suis fort mais voilà la
vue t2 est de pouvoir prendre le relais
et de pouvoir expertise et à mon tour
voilà vous parliez ou ne pas rester sur
des particules et finalement il ya
beaucoup de particuliers qui ont besoin
de restaurer du mobilier ancien surtout
des mobiliers du 17e au 19e siècle or
19e pouvons qu'en 17ème ça paraît
surprenant ça arrive encore 17-18
beaucoup
oui ils sont des clients qui ont souvent
une transmission de patrimoine familial
qui veut justement par la suite aussi
transmettre à leurs enfants et
petits-enfants donc c'est vraiment une
demande dire c'est sentimental donc on a
envie de pouvoir continuer à transmettre
voilà c'est ce sont les valeurs qui sont
qui sont les plus mises en avant par nos
clients ont longtemps l'histoire d'une
ville sentimentale frédéric debussche
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on doit conserver
ses heures il pas les laisser dépérir
oui puisse enfin sans toute cette
collection à saint quentin en yvelines
est vraiment
participe de l'identité du territoire on
a voulu construire ces villes nouvelles
finalement comme des villes anciennes
avec toutes leurs fonctionnalités du
visage mais aussi avec on appelle
parfois ce supplément d'âme qui sont ces
oeuvres en plein air quand on avait déjà
dans la ville ancienne dans la ville
antique aussi naturellement dans la
ville médiévale ou modernes donc c'est
une longue tradition
après il ya un changement il ya sûrement
dans le principe de commandes dans la
façon dont ces oeuvres sont sont
réalisés et puis naturellement dans
leurs courants stylistiques qui illustre
la les dernières années
deux dernières décennies du xxème siècle
et on a une vraie collection avec
différents courants
mais qui qui qui qui forment identité et
forme un peu le lien sur sur ce
territoire avec une caractéristique très
forte de cette de cette production qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de
villes nouvelles ou dans d'autres
aménagements urbains type la défense
c'est une politique que l'on retrouve
aussi sur les objets parce que le musée
de la villa se fera par quelques 6000
objets de collection vous faites
régulièrement des expositions
temporaires on porte la même politique
sur l'objet comme on peut y avoir sur le
mobilier ancien oui oui tout à fait
alors non à une collection particulière
en très peu de bois plutôt des objets
en plastique puisque notre collection
notamment de notre collection design et
mode de vie est essentiellement axée sur
les années 60 70 80 de la grande époque
des plastiques polymères et c'est enfin
et donc des problématiques de
restauration évidemment
avec une obligation puisqu'on et musées
de france de faire appel à des
restaurateurs diplômés évidemment pour
pour restaurer ses collections le
françoise lefèvre d'aspe restauration
d'oeuvres il est lié aussi à un
générique en 2018 et 70 da et suit le
travail autour d'un tableau du 16e
siècle retrouvée un an auparavant dans
un presbytère celui de la paroisse de
sartrouville on est aussi aux petits
seins vous avez des restaurateurs des
peintres si je peux me permettre qu'ils
sont là pour redonner de l'éclat à cette
histoire yvelinoise
le ingénierie le pôle patrimoine
d'ingénierie accompagne les communes
cette fois ci beaucoup plus profondément
que pour la restauration des édifices
parce que c'est une compétence que les
communes n'ont pas donc nous avons au
sein du service de conservatrice qui
vont conseiller les communes et qui vont
prendre la maîtrise d'ouvragé sur sur
ces restaurations et qui vont
sélectionner les restaurateurs qui vont
travailler sur les tableaux parfois le
résultat est spectaculaire parce que il
faut
là vous parliez de sartrouville moi j'ai
un autre exemple en tête dans une autre
commune perdre aux villes où le tableau
n'était plus un tableau c'est un c'était
une ça ressemblait à un morceau de toile
cirée ou une serpillière qui a été
retrouvée qui n'avait même plus de
châssis
retrouver à l'occasion d'un nettoyage
dans le dans la sacristie et il a fallu
déjà
reconnaître que c'était un tableau
ancien
convaincre après la commune
du besoin de faire restaurer ces il ya
eu une première intervention d'urgence
qui a consisté à coller des papiers sur
la surface de l'oeuvre pourrait empêcher
que tous s'en aille et en collant le
fait du midi fils
la surface a permis de faire ressortir
le dessin qui était complètement cachée
sous la crasse et
7 cette première intervention d'urgence
a pu derrière tirer le fil pour pour
convaincre les différents partenaires
que non seulement c'était intéressant
mais en plus derrière il a pu être
présenté au classement donc c'est un
tableau du xviie c'est un sujet
religieux mais c'est une facture
exceptionnelle et qui c'est qui était
dans une sacristie et grâce au travail
des restaurateurs des conservateurs tout
ça a pu revenir mais ce genre de
découverte sa race et liège alors vous
avez une très jeune carrière encore mais
peut-être qu'avec monsieur de lavalade
quand vous en avez parlé est ce que des
fois on découvre des pépites auquel on
ne s'attendait pas alors ce sont souvent
les clients qui viennent nous
qui veut nous voir demander nous faire
donc une expertise demandée si ce meuble
et d'époque ou de style est
effectivement souvent j'ai encore eu
l'exemple aujourd'hui d un couple de
clients qui sont passés en me disant pas
cette commode elle est dix neuvième donc
elle vaut pas grand chose en arrivant on
a vu arriver cette commode et en fait
non elle était bonne d'époque qu'elle
était fin xviiie donc louis saez et est
d'époque et qu'il n'y croyait pas donc
c'est vrai que ça peut arriver d'avoir
des greniers oui oui ça arrive ça arrive
aussi et puis les gens les ont délaissé
en se disant que ça ne valait plus ça ne
valait pas la peine de restaurer et puis
en fait avec le temps soit s'est
transmis soit ça a été vendu ou ça a été
retrouvée comme vous dites dans un
grenier là là quelqu'un s'y intéresse et
nous et nous le donne à restaurer et
c'est comme ça que ça c'est comme ça
qu'on retrouve de très belle très belle
pièce j'ai même vu que ça il ya un
certain plaisir finalement quand on
découvre cette petite c'est quelque
chose auquel on s'y attend pas ce qu'on
s'y connaît mais finalement le client ou
la commune se dit ah oui on avait quand
même ce trésor sans pareil
financièrement 13 ans chez nous oui
effectivement quand on parle de 13
heures n'ont pas trader sentimentale pas
financier et puis
d'époque donc effectivement les gens
sont surpris dans le bon sens et puis
effectivement après on encore plus
l'envi le coeur de faire restaurer ses
besoins de ces objets là
pareil du côté des communes où
finalement on se dit ah mais non
finalement là aussi ça dans un placard
on as à cet endroit
je pensais d'autres communes aussi ou
l'occasion de travaux dans l'église pour
refaire l'enduit
là il ya eu un premier piquetage qui a
révélé des anglais pas
anciens et en dégageant petit à petit
les travaux sont arrêtés et du coup
après l'ensemble a été dégagé alors
qu'au départ personne n'était très
enthousiastes à l'idée de faire ces
travaux et bien finalement
c'est un c'est un saint christophe qui
est apparu tout le monde connaît le
saint christophe qui porte le christ qui
fait le passeur
et c'est une découverte exceptionnelle
aussi la fin 14e début 15e et la commune
du coup se retrouvent
fier de posséder cette cette oeuvre qui
a permis en plus elle est protégée du
coup l'église est protégé pour les
communes dimension exceptionnelle et
fred avec début je vais terminer avec
vous donc on relève les prix vous ce
sont des oeuvres plus récentes celles
qu'elle fait l'actualité c'est la
perspective de marta pan elle va
retrouver son éclat alors oui la fin
peut pas tout dit y voir un petit peu de
petit peu de temps c'est une oeuvre qui
a effectivement fait l'objet d'une étude
préalable
qui a été rendu il ya déjà presque deux
ans maintenant en 2020 et sur la base de
cette étude on pourra prochainement elle
espère lancer la restauration alors
d'abord un marché de maîtrise d'oeuvre
et puis après j'ai travaux on est on est
sur des oeuvres qui sont finalement plus
de l'ordre du monumental
c'est beaucoup plus proche d'un des
bâtiments antiques de restauration est
une oeuvre ou qu'un élément de mobilier
par les gaullistes et cyril va le
déplacer sur
on est sur du temps du temps
relativement long mais qui qui m'a vite
parce que c'est une des oeuvres majeures
du territoire et il faut nous on n'est
pas dans ce phénomène de redécouvrir ou
de découverte 9 quand on peut la voir
dans des églises mais à chaque fois une
étude et le fait se pencher comme ça de
façon plus précise sur une oeuvre permet
de donner la comprendre et dans un sens
aussi la redécouvrir et qui permet de
comprendre à travers une oeuvre comme
martin peau comme marta pan les choix
éclairé qui ont qui ont pu être faits à
l'époque sur sur des artistes retenus
pour pour ses commandes publiques
c'est quand manière de redécouvrir
l'oeuvre que de s'y intéresser pour sa
restauration
je propose qu'on s'arrête sur ces mots
merci à tous les trois d'être venu sur
ce plateau pour parler de comment on
travaille on respecte le patrimoine
yvelinois bien sûr là y compris ceux
cette société maintenant terminé merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
est bien sûr d'ici là prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]
il